this is a belt i promised i didn't try
to match it this is just the first one i
picked up i would have brought another
one if i realized what i was wearing
today
what's up gq i'm vince staples and these
are my essentials
[Music]
this is a rosemary and eucalyptus body
oil
from noir grooming by natasha in los
angeles california
one thing about black people is that we
get ashy and sometimes we get greasy
so it's a perfect balance to not be ashy
not be greasy
and not you know jergens johnson and
johnson like you know all due respect
but that's that no we're getting too
much money
for jergens or johnson and johnson we're
not doing that you take this you get two
drops you rub it in you go about your
day
you don't want to look too shiny you
don't want to look too mad it's a
perfect balance
so make sure you go support i don't know
the website but i know she got one
it's good for you stop using jargons
it's weird so vince can you tell us
about your
your moisturizing routine i'm happy ux
is a big disconnect
in all of our communities black people
moisturize at all times
when you wake up when you go to sleep
throughout the day i have a tour manager
named danny wildsby great guy hey danny
danny told us he doesn't wear lotion
he never has he never will it's just a
thing he does but danny also puts his
jeans in the freezer on the tour bus
next to the eggos
tell me if you trust a man who puts the
jeans
by the eggos you know simple question
hey danny
this is a water by hiroshi a diffuser
fragrance oil
it's barney you put this in a little
diffuser from muji or wherever you
decide to get your diffusers from
put this in the water let it run
throughout the whole house and it's like
a brand new house because you know you
might get a little cabin fever
based on not being able to leave because
we're in a pandemic i like this a lot we
got one in every room
different flavors you're not getting all
the flavors but you got to make sure
when you walk in different parts of the
house it's a different experience
for you and yours so this is the thing
about the candles my ceilings are too
high and i like the windows to be open
sometimes with the candle it's a fire
hazard
putting smoke in the environment i don't
know if that's a fire hazard but i got
asthma so something about smoke just
doesn't intrigue me
but yeah with these you know you get it
right away you put the water in the
environment you know what i'm saying you
add to the humidity
i got the vivint security system so i
can monitor the humidity in each room
i can almost promise you that this acid
humidity is good for your skin it's good
for everything so
make sure that you use diffuser oils
just not the ones i use because i'm
gonna get offended if you steal
for me this is a comb de garcon perfume
it's old it's a little raggedy
i didn't buy stuff for this y'all aren't
that special this is the only one i'm
willing to give up i have several
i have one for the car we have one for
if it's a cold day one if it's a hot day
these fragrances kind of differ based on
where you're going how you're living
sometimes you might want something like
more
musky if you might be thinking going to
jail that day or if you think you might
have a court date
sometimes you need something sweetie if
you're going to see your grandma it all
depends on what you're doing
this is kind of the balance
kind of robust floral i would say
not too musky but not too musty i pair
this with like a dove
fresh powder scent you know what i mean
we don't do eggs we don't do old spice
that's for racist people i don't bring
this out for the special occasions but
say i'm going to the car wash
see i'm going to like a candle light
visual this is what i'll throw on
come to garcon dot make sure you go get
it
[Music]
this is a yankee hat i don't wear hats
but i make sure if i do have to wear a
hat is this hat holds a lot of symbolism
for me i'm a big fan of yogi berra
derek jeter dale strawberry i really
love the sport
this is by the internal knowledge chess
club i overpaid for this hat because it
was brown
and i just saw queen's gambit so it was
a lot of different things that made me
love it
but yeah i have a yankee head in my
trunk i have one in my front
i usually have a couple on the road in
case i can't get a haircut
i would say about two to three yankee
hats within a reaching distance per day
just to keep me you know leveled out
make sure that i'm i'm centered and i
remember the things that are dear to me
this is an albuterol sulfate it's an
asthma pump i have chronic asthma i
almost died at coachella
i almost died at red rocks twice almost
died in spain
i almost died at pe at mayfair high
school in ninth grade i almost died
at the racial riot jordan summer school
i think that was 0809 one of those
things and this keeps me alive i was
just watching your honor
and you know this is the last thing that
adam saw before you know his untimely
demise sorry for the spoiler but it's
very very integral to my life i have
about 174 puffs left
so hopefully they last until you know i
need another one because i forget to get
these a lot i have about three that are
lost
corey has one i think danny wiseby has
one tyler page has one i gotta spread
them around in case i'm ever around
somebody and
almost die so you know this has saved me
a couple times
i like the blue ones they had a little
bit more you know torque
i just wait damn i wasted that
[Music]
these are pomades now if you've ever
seen or read the outsiders you
understand pomade is very integral
to life on the streets this is a sleek
water light pomade by frederick benjamin
i'm pretty sure
this is like if you go into the grocery
store really quick you don't need
anything too thick you might be right
back home
because it's not lasting that long but
it's not that heavy you know it's good
for your pores
this is american crew grooming now this
is kind of thicker it's almost like a
petroleum like gasoline type of thing
this is what they use before they flick
the razor blade this is what fonzie had
this will last you all day maybe two
days but the integral part
is the scotch porter hair bone you throw
this on the bottom really get the waves
going
really make sure they stay in place i
got a cowlick then i got a weird hair
pattern to grow like that you know like
that so like
i gotta make sure it's laying flat or
i'm gonna look like i'm balding and
there's a lot of people missing hair
these days
i don't want to be one of them so make
sure you know if you're losing your hair
cut it against the grain get it one low
or just be bald don't embarrass yourself
okay this is a belt belts are very
integral to life
you might need to get up out of there
you might need to go somewhere you know
if you don't have a belt
and i can see your bottom i will judge
you
it's not attractive it won't make you
hard no one wants to see your ethics
we're not doing ethicas
it doesn't even sound right
this is a japanese peach water by
coca-cola i don't know what it says but
i know this is japanese and i know it's
by coca-cola
we went to kyoto it was a whole ordeal
and we were walking through a forest and
it was 100 degrees
and this is the only water they had and
it's delicious so with that being said
this is an essential thing for me
because i almost died and you almost die
every day so make sure to drink some
water flavored or not flavored
so make sure it's not sparkling
okay this is a wallet i've seen a lot of
these a lot of people don't have their
wallet or their keys or their phone
you're lying you don't need all that
jewelry or that
box of cereal or like those shoes you're
a liar this is important i have my sad
card
shout out to the screen actors guild i
got a room and board gift card
i haven't used i have a 200 gift card
i haven't used i got this for christmas
i got a tile
i think yeah it works i thought it was
dead i got my driver's license
i got some insurance cards that are
expired but i have them in my email oh i
have my
california department of justice firearm
safety certificate
i'm working on my ccw i have a fully
expunged record so
the sheriff of where i live at watch
this i'm a good guy
no cash in the wallet oh no cash is for
people not yourself i'm not giving
anyone anything no it's not my thing
[Music]
this is a kn 95 mass due to us being in
a panda bear you have to make sure that
you're safe
at all times you have the little cute
ones with the designs and the aesthetics
and all that stuff
it's not going to keep you alive you're
going to die so you have to make sure
you have the correct filtration this is
what they give the firefighters and the
army men
so make sure that you have one of these
when you go to the whole foods don't
yell
in the cvs about how it's your
constitutional right
to not have a mask because then you're a
bad person and we don't tolerate bad
people in 2021 it's a new day
and that's what this is for thank you
for checking out my essentials
once again it's vince staples see you
guys later